je vais vous interrogez uniquement sur
le permis de port d'armes qui a été
délivré à monsieur benalla madame jourda
posera toute une série d'autres
questions
en complément d'abord ce permis de port
d'armes dont nous avons le document et
vous connaissez ce document puisqu'il a
été rédigée je pense pas aux soins ou
sous votre contrôle
voilà il est étrange à beaucoup d'égards
et je voulais vous demander d'abord qui
en a formellement fait la demande au nom
de la présidence de la république
tu trouves monsieur le co-rapporteur
c'est une question importante et qui
nécessite que je prenne le temps de
réponse pour détailler l'ensemble de la
procédure
le 5 octobre 2017
les services de la direction de la
police générale de la préfecture de
police
m'informe de la réception d'une demande
de port d'armes de la part de monsieur
benalla chargé de mission à la
présidence de la république
en l'absence de directeur au sein de
cette direction le poste était tout
simplement vacances à cette période là
les services souhaite que le cabinet du
préfet de police évoque le dossier à son
niveau c'est donc par l'intermédiaire
des services administratifs de la
préfecture de police que je prends
connaissance de cette demande
j'informe alors le préfet de police qui
me demande de me rapprocher du cabinet
du président de la république afin que
le dossier nous parviennent par la voie
hiérarchique le 10 octobre 2010 est le
directeur du cabinet du président de la
république confirme la demande par
courriel et sollicite son examen sur le
fondement de l'article l 315 tirer 1 du
code de la sécurité intérieure et ce
essais marqués dans le courriel de
transmission dans le strict respect des
textes
ce sont là les seuls liens que nous
avons lu avec le cabinet du président de
la république sur ce dossier ne paraît
utile de faire un point sur les textes
mobilisés dans cet arrêté si vous me
permettez l'article l 315 tirer 1 du
code de la sécurité intérieure dispose
que les fonctionnaires et agents des
administrations publiques exposé par
leurs fonctions à des risques
d'agression peuvent être autorisées à
fermer dans le cadre de leurs fonctions
ces dispositions sont codifiés dans le
code de la sécurité intérieure et j'en
viens aux articles qu'on va mentionné
dans l'arrêté l'article l311 r300 12-24
du code précité dispose que les
fonctionnaires et agents des
administrations publiques chargées d'une
mission de police et où et ou exposées à
des risques d'agression peuvent être
autorisés à acquérir et à détenir des
armes
la situation d'alexandre benalla
correspondant à ce cas de figure nous
avons donc lancé à ce moment là
l'instruction du dossier
en veillant à réunir l'ensemble des
pièces nécessaires le carnet tirer
formation continue le certificat médical
l' enquête de moralité et c'est après un
examen approfondi du dossier
il est apparu que le dossier était
complet et que les missions de monsieur
benalla rentrait dans le cadre fixé par
le législateur
ainsi considérant l'action d'alexandre
benalla de coordination de sécurité de
la présidence de la république avec les
forces militaires et le gspr considérant
qu'il exerçait sa mission auprès du
président de la république
qui fait l'objet de nombreuses menaces
et dans un contexte au niveau de menace
terroriste n'a jamais été aussi élevé et
considérant qu'ils étaient de fait
manifestement exposés à des risques
d'agression
c'est ça qui est écrit dans l'arrêté le
préfet de police a validé sa demande et
j'ai signé le 13 octobre 2017 par
délégation du préfet de police
l'autorisation de port d'armes de
monsieur benalla une autorisation que
nous avons limité strictement à
l'exercice de ses missions et à la
validité de son contrat à la présidence
de la république
mais monsieur brou et j'entends ce que
vous dites mais monsieur le secrétaire
général de l'elysée monsieur le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république et monsieur le chef de
cabinet nous ont affirmé que monsieur
benalla n'exercez pas de missions de
police
tout le monde ici a entendu cela or je
me suis déjà étonné auprès d'eux comme
je m'étonne auprès de vous que le permis
de port d'armes portent la mention
suivante je crois que notre président en
disposent
considérant que monsieur benalla est
chargé d'une mission de police
alors c'est clair c'est net et c'est
précis alors autre question vous avez
dit que la demande a été faite par un
courriel
ce matin même monsieur benalla nous a
dit qu'elle avait été faite par
téléphone s'il s'agit d'un courriel
je suppose que ce courriel existe
toujours
car nous nous avons demandé le document
par lequel l'elysée
donc le directeur de cabinet a demandé
le port d'armes et il a été refusé de
nous communiquer cette pièce est ce que
vous disposez toujours je suppose que
vous ne disposez pas de ce courriel mais
je suppose que dans les archives de la
préfecture de police
ils figurent et est-ce que vous avez le
sou
nir précis des mentions qui figurait sur
ce courriel
parce que de deux choses l'une où ce
sont ce les mentions c'est que monsieur
benalla exerce des missions de police
et cela invalide les déclarations qui
ont été faites à la fois par le
secrétaire général le directeur de
gamine et le chef de cabinet ou alors on
ne comprend pas tiendrez vous allez pas
vous avez la part de choses il ya une
question en deux temps je vais je vais
commencer par la seconde qui est le
courriel je le confirme
sous serment c'est un courriel du
directeur de cabinet du président éric
qui a déclenché l'instruction du dossier
dans ce courriel je le cite de mémoire
ça fait un certain temps et je veux
quelqu'un y avait marqué qu on avait été
informé de cette demande que monsieur
strzoda confirmé cette demande et qu'ils
nous demandait de l'instruire sur le
fondement de l'article l 315 tirer 1 du
code de la sécurité intérieure et ce
dans le strict respect des textes
point final c'est la transmission avec
toutes les pièces justificatives au
dossier voilà qui peut paraître
surprenant qu'il soit nécessaire que le
directeur de cabinet précise que c'est
dans le strict respect des textes qui
vous demande d'instruire une demande de
permis de port d'armes
parce que ça pourrait aller de soi on
pourrait imaginer que ça va de soi mais
plaît